This Test shows an SPF 45 powder giving
great coverage that means it's not a
good test for SPF the way the brand got
this SPF 45 label is a lab measured the
real protection of the powder on actual
skin at two milligrams per square
centimeter that translates to around
this much powder she didn't apply
anywhere near this much so she's getting
way lower than SPF 45. there are lots of
microscopic holes that the UV is getting
through that we just can't see in this
video but in the proper SPF test the UV
got through and burned the volunteer
skin even when it was caked on also the
65 US brush only has three or four full
face applications that's like twenty
dollars an application